[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 7 skin of her
teeth wow so we are really cooking right
now in this season and this episode one
of the short episodes of the season of
45 minutes still felt like i just
watched only five minutes of television
and that's really television at its best
and what's happening here in the season
right now is
it's showing you when a tv show is just
grooving that
everything that's culminated all the
past episodes to get to this is just
clicking now and it's rewarding so like
i literally felt like i was clenching my
butt this whole episode which is always
good it's like when you eat a meal and
you're so into the meal that you forget
where you are it's like an out-of-body
experience that's kind of what i felt
this episode i didn't expect that like i
forgot i was even in my apartment
watching it when it ended i was like
it's over like that had me so invested
so what is really interesting to me
about this episode is what's said in the
middle episode by dexter in a narration
is he used to be the predator he says
but now i'm the protector funny what
fatherhood will do to you this is such
an important line to me and is the name
of the game for this episode and what's
actually going on here because this was
really set up well to start this episode
because
it's setting up how much dexter really
does want to protect harrison and
because of that he's doing a good thing
for harrison that
he's really messing up his own game as a
serial killer and it's going to be his
downfall clearly but dexter doesn't want
to have harrison lose someone again
without knowing who they really are so
he's like i'd rather leave it to the
police to handle because he knows if he
kills curt
that that's going to be another tragic
ending for harrison so he doesn't want
that but you know dev's like okay we
know what happens when we have the
police you know take care of things what
could possibly go wrong she said
sarcastically so
it's so true and you'll see as the
episode goes on that dexter is coming
around to what dev in his head was
saying and i love too after dexter we
get to see do his friends at work again
which was awesome with angela
you know he has a great narration that
really felt like dexter of old
where he's like where does this journey
end with angel and the police or me and
my kill table referencing kurt and
what's happening here where you're
seeing dexter off his game is
he spills molly's secret which was
really when you're watching it you're
like this is not a good idea because him
just bringing angela to kurt's cabin
he's leading angela to figure this all
out he's giving her the bread crumbs
right so the police take care of this
like he wants but this is so risky by
dexter and he's doing this to protect
his son but it's already setting up this
sketchy vibe for angela and for molly
later on they connect all the dots about
like this is bizarre behavior by dexter
and
him following molly that day as jim
lindsey and she knows more obviously
angela that he's actually dexter but
him just having these like very
not strong reasons for being there like
why is he following molly and all this
stuff so we'll get more into that but
again it's just dangerous territory what
he's doing and it really doesn't pay off
because kurt already cleared the scene
he's like he says in this episode the
brilliant thing about kurt as a killer
it's like a chess game he always makes
you think you're one step ahead but
you're really not and it's actually for
me bringing kurt up on let's say the
rankings of serial killers in
dexter so far as the villains i think
this brings them up this episode clearly
and we're gonna get into clancy brown's
fantastic performance this episode in a
second there's also a very important
moment that kind of just sneaks in here
real quick with harrison and audrey
because you know he was just getting
really close to audrey and she was
understanding him and then she really
got freaked out by him snapping that
guy's arm at the wrestling match so
it's more to just set him off that
audrey's pushing him away which is scary
that's when i start getting really
scared of harrison
and i like they do a little fake out
shot after
that is reminiscent of dexter the way
they shot it too or him putting on the
dexter outfit you think he's gonna have
someone on the table but he's just going
to work here for kurt but i like that i
thought that was a nice misdirect and if
things couldn't get any tenser having
this little showdown between caldwell
and dexter at the diners great
television this is what stuff people
love to watch having our main
protagonist our antagonist kind of going
head-to-head here but you're already
getting a tease of that kurt's got
something on dexter because he's talking
about the fate of them meeting that
night with the snow falling but dexter
still thinks he's got the win here
because angela shows up it's a match on
the dna and what i did think was funny
too if you caught it was when
dexter then texts angela to know if
kurt's talking there's a little text
conversation prior you see the end of
and dexter says no you you don't i was
even more boring back then i thought
that was funny some kind of conversation
maybe her just wanted to know more about
the real dexter i thought that was
actually a nice touch and had some humor
to it but see now this mystery truck
driver who's working for kurt gives
harrison this note and this is when you
knew trouble was coming when he said
give this to your dad and this is when
dexter is like what the f is this what's
your game kurt so one of my mini gripes
here in this episode is i know when
dexter goes to police station teddy left
right and he's been to this police
station obviously because he's dating
angela but it still is a little bizarre
like how at night did he get into
that police station where the cells are
that time that that if they have kurt
say how did you get in here but there's
no justification really i think we just
kind of got to suspend our disbelief a
little bit i do think they could have
written some way to make that a little
more believable but we get to see which
we kind of expected obviously that kurt
is a man who has power in the town
obviously but power even behind bars my
favorite writing in this episode is when
dexter says to kurt you think you can
get rid of everything something always
gets left behind and kurt says you're
right we can never get rid of all our
sins not even fire can do that so this
is was like the jaw-dropping moment for
me and
i love he brings up how it wasn't snow
in his jacket it was ash he connected
that dot and then he clearly went to
where he burnt matt's body and the
titanium was there so titanium doesn't
melt he says to dexter so it was a
titanium screws in matt's leg that we
saw the scar of that was such a clever
twist especially in the time of reddit i
mean maybe i'm wrong i don't know if
anyone else saw it but i saw no one
predict this so to me this was an
excellent reveal that little detail of
seeing that scar and matt comes back now
and that really just screwed dexter over
thinking again that he gets
away with everything smoothly but he
left a big thing behind and this has to
terrify dexter now because he even says
line if it was him he would want revenge
so now he has to be on harrison like a
hawk now he's really got to consider
actually just taking care of kurt
himself and speaking of kurt let's go
back to the actor here so clancy brown
to me this was the scene of the season
acting wise for him and maybe any of the
actors in the show
when he's talking about his abusive
drunk father
and
it shows in the flashbacks that his
father would beat these girls it's
traumatic childhood that song we always
hear him playing was playing on the
record player in the truck and he's like
i lived in fear he would turn on me like
that which is definitely a truthful
statement by him but what can get
confusing on first watch and you should
watch the scene twice just to really
process everything that's going on is
that you know he's saying to angela that
he saw his dad in such a foul mood that
night pick up iris should have stopped
him but he ends it as they drove off and
that's the last he saw a virus but we
see actually what's going on in the
visual is that
kurt is the driver he says his name is
kurt and you know he originally did
suggest to take her back home knowing
how bad it was out there for a girl
at night in that area knowing how his
dad is but he shot her with this rifle
when running away so this is huge
because this is the first step to
learning about his mo here and why he
recreates this scene we still don't know
the embalming part why that's a thing
yet which is definitely gonna be
revealed soon which is exciting but that
that was interesting but it's a smart
move by kurt because like you know it's
a dna thing he's going against he's
gonna pin it on his own father that he
hates and it weakens the case for angela
but angela knows he's full of van he
offers the handshake and she doesn't
even give it back but where i want to
hit with angela here is it's so
interesting when molly sees angela you
know this is bad news because
molly brings up jim is like a little
weird and creepy right and that why was
he following me and they connect from
where they're sitting at the bar
the convo distance that there's no way
dexter would have heard her and kurt
talking that he must have recorded them
and angela then says it's also weird he
was eating pie with card after he knew
as a prime suspect this is all the slop
that dexter's been doing to protect his
son not making sure he's keeping his
cover to angela and people like molly
still and she says molly i would totally
do a deep dive not like he's hiding
anything from you you're the chief
police but we know and angela knows he
did
just his identity of course so this is
bad news for dexter and this is the
start of what you could see from last
episode that we're going towards this
downfall of dexter you know there's
going to be some sort of tragic engine
here and dexter seems like going to get
caught by the police but also he's in
trouble with another serial killer so he
goes to kurt's office looking for the
other screw right and he finds another
envelope with a check from elder kane
for five thousand dollars so this
clearly
is the man paying him for whatever he
wants these embalmed bodies for so i
want to hear the theories on that where
that's going right and dexter over here
is the diner workers say that kirk got
released so he's like yep i'm gonna have
to kill him but again this is too late
for dexter but we also see harrison goes
to swipe the wrestlers here are giving
him crap for hurting their friend with
the trini blade but dexter stops him and
this leads to a nice moment with dexter
and harrison they're finally getting
this dirty laundry out like i'm fed up
they weren't nightmares they were real
i'm so angry everything happened with
his mom the trinity killer i think about
all the time and hurting people he says
to dexter which is huge that's a huge
moment but of course i've seen a lot of
commenters mention this how it's
frustrating harrison and scenes running
away it's like especially in this one
because we're finally getting to things
with him and dexter like we're making
progress here between the two and then
he runs away
but i was also a little frustrated too
that i hate i've already made my
complaint about this i hate they do like
a preview of the episode in the episode
where they show little clips what's to
come they didn't need to show harrison
swiping with the training blade that was
kind of too much of a giveaway it kind
of took away from that moment for sure
but you see dexter's like i was wrong i
have to tell harrison everything this
big character changes this big
realization too late though cause kurt's
watching them here and the mystery truck
driver gets dexter
wow what a cliffhanger and it's really
exciting now to see we still have three
episodes left
so what is gonna happen here especially
the last two episodes building up so
much momentum so intense i mean it's
just making the sky the limit here for
these last episodes and what we're going
to see but i'm going to predict too that
like we're going to this now that
dexter's in serious trouble and
this is going to be something where
harrison
you know is probably gonna go to try
save dexter
um and stuff's gonna hit the fan with
the cops with dexter and i still don't
think harrison is this like killer um
i think they're just gonna kind of maybe
make him as someone who'll go to
extremes to protect his dad at this
point but
i think it's like a lot of red herrings
with harrison here throughout the season
communism is just a red herring and it
might just be something where like he's
tempted to become like his father at the
end he chooses not to so we'll see um i
hope they land this well i think they
will it's it's just all clicking now and
really feels like no scene is wasted
here and
i always someone you know i was hard on
episode five i bashed it but that was
one of the writers on this episode so
i'm obviously give credit when they do a
great job and i think this was a way
better job by them so props to that
writer you go and do something like this
and totally redeem yourself and yeah i'm
excited i'm giving this one a 9.4 i
actually think this was the best episode
of the season but part of that's too
because everything's kind of clicking
that was set up so well so
uh yeah i just think we're in a great
zone of television for the show i'm
excited to see what's going to happen
next let me know what you think down
below i read every comment i try to
respond as many as i can give me any
theories you got and please follow me at
steve barley show on twitter instagram
for more of me and if you love what i do
here i really appreciate if you can
become a member today it will help me do
more reviews for you guys and you get
special perks as well and i'll see you
next time